[موسيقى]
امال السعدي هي هي رياضيه التكنولوجيا
باكثر من 22 عاما من الخبره قبل ما تحقق
حلمها وتاسس شركه تطوير البرمجيات
حققت نجاحات وتطورات عظيمه في شركه
اسكدنيا خريجه ومفخر جامعتنا جامعه
الاميره سميه للتكنولوجيا وحتحدثنا
[تصفيق]
وحتحدثنا عن مستقبل الويب
رحبوا معي بامال السعدي
[تصفيق]
بس قبل ما ابلش بصير اسال سؤال الباب هناك
طيب مرحبا جميعا طبعا انا مش شايفه للاسف
مع الاضاءه بس
[موسيقى]
هيك احسن
طيب يعطيكم العافيه جميعا بعرف اليوم
سمعتوا كتير امور دسمه بس ان شاء الله
اليوم في مع انه عالم الويب 3 كبير بس راح
نحاول يكون ان شاء الله شوي
مندخلش في تفاصيل معقده او تعقيدات
في 94 كنت ايامها لسه بالمدرسه وانا
متاكده يمكن في ناس لسه مش مولده 94 هلا
بعرف الجيل هون شوي فوق ال 94 بس ايام ما
كنت في المدرسه شاركت مقال مع زميلاتي في
الصف عن اشي كان بالنسبه لالي ما بدي احكي
خيال هو اشي مخي ابدا ما كان مستوعبه كان
المقال قاعد يحكي عن جاكيت انا بقدر اليوم
البسه وهذا الجاكيت انا بقدر اتحكم في
درجه حرارته هذا بال 94 يعني بقدر اجي اذا
الدنيا شوب كتير ابرد درجه الحراره تاعت
الجاكيت واذا كتير برد دفي درجه الجاكيت
زي كاني لابسه كندشن بس بتحكم فيه باز
جاكيت طبعا ليش هذا الحكي كان وقتها
بالنسبه لالي عن جد خيال علمي لانه لسه ما
كنا احنا الناس على الانترنت وما بنعرف
كيف في اشي في يوم من الايام راح يطلع
اسمه الانترنت اوف ثانكس او انترنت
الاشياء
في 96 انا تعرفت على صديق لالي كنت اقعد
معه بالساعات بصراحه مع انه صوته كان مزعج
كثير مين برفع الاصابع كان لحق اشي اسمه
مودم وصوته بطلع عشان
بالنسبه لالي مع انه كان صوته مزعج بس هذا
الاختراع كان اكثر اشي رهيب في حياتي لانه
كنا عم ننتقل من عالم الكتب لعالم اني انا
اقدر ادخل على مواقع الكترونيه واقدر اشوف
فيها معلومات عن الشركات بس كان وقتها هذا
الحكي
جدا بسيط كان يعني بتلخص في عمليه اني
اليوم انا بس عم بقرا معلومات موجوده على
الانترنت بدخل عدد الموقع لشركه اكس وفي
هذا الموقع بس عم بشوف انا معلوماتها
الاستاتيك ما عم بتفاعل معها طبعا
بعديها اجا عنا خلينا نحكي اليوم عصر
الويب اللي هو يمكن جميعكم عم بتعامل معه
او تفاعل معه
اللي هو نوعا ما اختلاف عن الويب 1 انه
انا مش بس بقدر اقرا انا بقدر اكتب
وكلياتنا عشنا اليوم فيسبوك يوتيوب
تويتر كلياتها منصات ما هي نفسها كونتنت
يعني ما بيجي فيسبوك بكون هو حاطط فيها
احنا لا احنا اللي عم نحط لكم هذا كان
اسمه نوعا ما العصر التشاركي انه انا بوفر
منصه والناس هي اللي عم بتحط لكم على اساس
يصير في عنا اليوم معلومات طبعا هاي
المنصات او الحياه اللي عم نعيشها هلا
عندنا شويه مشاكل في حدا ممكن يعرف شو
ممكن اكبر مشكله موجوده بحياتنا هلا في
هذا العالم التشاركي
انا مو شايفه بس تفضل
مصداقيه ممكن بس
تفضلي
ما سمعت
حلو
سكيوريتي حلو
ما سمعتش
اوكي هلا هو الصراحه في كتير امور بس
اهمها هلا راح نلخصها في قصه فرح
خلينا نحكي عن فرح اليوم بتصحى الصبح فرح
بتكون طبعا بدها تقوم اول اشي كلياتنا
يمكن وفرح منكم بتشيك موبايلها بتشوف انه
انا في الموبايل اليوم بدي اشوف شو جدول
اعمالي شو في عندي نشاطات شو في ايميلات
وبتدخل على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي عشان
تكون ابتوديت مع الاحداث اللي موجوده في
المجتمع اللي هي عايشه فيه طبعا فرح راح
تاخذ موبايلها تطلع من البيت
وتطلب سياره سيارات خليني احكي التنقل
التشاركي اللي موجوده حاليا عنا في
الماركت
وبتتعامل خليني احكي اليوم
هي عارفه انها مضطره تحط معلوماتها عشان
تعمل
وتطلع تاخذ السياره هاي وتطلع على مكان
شغلها بس هي عارفه فرح انه هاي معلوماتها
الشخصيه موجوده عند هاي الشركه اللي طلعت
معاها
والناس عارفين وين رحلاتها او الشركه مش
الناس الشركه اللي عم تستخدمها تتعامل
معاها
لهذا الشخص ولا لا بس طلعت على مكتبها
وكانت عم تشتغل في شركه عم بشتغلوا على
مشروع للبيئه بس هذا المشروع مبني على
تقنيه الويب 2
وما عم بقدر خلينا نحكي اليوم
بياخدوا قرارات غير قرارات مركزيه يعني عم
بضطر هو يروحوا لاصحاب المشروع عشان
ياخذوا قرارات ويمشوا فيها
في المساء بتطلع فرح بتجيها دعوه على تحضر
ايفنت تيكس سميه بس على
لايف ستريمنج على السوشيال ميديا طبعا هنا
بتكون فرح قاعده على الجهاز بس فعليا ما
عم تتفاعل معهم غير بالتيكس مسجز لانه
العالم هذا موجود
طبعا قلنا بنعيش القلق اللي عايشته فرح زي
ما حكينا بالقبل بس اهم اشي كان نوعا ما
في حياه فرح مقلق هو الخصوصيه خصوصيه
معلوماتها كل نهارها ويمكن احنا كلياتنا
بنروح اماكن اكثر وبنتفاعل اكثر بس كل
نهارنا بكون فيه اشياء احنا قلقانين هل
هاي المعلومه ضلت محميه الشركه اللي حطيت
فيها هاي المعلومه هل راح تحتفظ في
معلوماتي ولا راح
تعرضها للبيع او على اي امور مثل هذا يعني
نوعا ما هذا اللي طلع فيه عالم الويب 3
هذا سبب رئيسي كان طالع فيه الويب ثري
اليوم اذا بدنا نعيش نفس قصه فرح اليوم
انا نسيت السلايدز على فكره
اذا بدنا نعيش نفس قصه فرح او اعيدها بس
على عالم الويب 3
اليوم فرح عم تصحى الصبح عايشه طبعا في
مدينه ذكيه اليوم تصحى الصبح بتلاقي شبكه
الويب الخاصه فيها رتبت لها مواعيدها
والسكينجوال تاعها واعطتها ابرز خليني
احكي الاحداث
يعني بسبب انها هي حاطه مفضلات وحاطه امور
عم تعتمد عليها خليني احكي اليوم شبكه
الويب الخاصه فيها على اساس تطلع لها
المعلومات
فما اخذت وقت كتير عشان تجيب هاي
المعلومات وما احتاجت انه تضيع وقت طويل
انها تقرا كل الاخبار بس عشان تعرف شو
اللي هي مهتمه فيها يعني هي اليوم مهتمه
في اخبار الاردن في الويب تو كانت عم تضطر
تقرا كل اخبار العالم او تدور اكتر عشان
تشوف اخبار الاردن بس طبعا مش بس هيك
اليوم
المنبه اللي موجود على تلفون فرح وصحاها
الصبح اعطى اوامر
خليني احكي جهاز عنده في البيت عشان يشغل
التدفئه وتكون يعني البيت دافي
ومش بس هيك كمان قهوتها تكون جاهزه تمام
راحت برضه نفس الاشي خلينا نحكي طلعت على
المقهى عشان تشوف اصحابها
وصلت هناك شردت قهوتها ودفعت
اندفعت بالعمله الرقميه
ولما بلش النقاش حوالين الرسمه اللي هي
الفنان عاملها قدروا بسرعه تشوفوا على
اصول ويقدروا يتبعوا التاريخ الفني لهذا
الفنان اللي هي عن طريق خليني احكي اليوم
الويب فري وال nftes انا بقدر اشوف كل
اصول او تتبع لكل الاصول لهاي العمل الفني
واذا هي فعلا نادره او مش نادره طبعا راحت
على شغلها
ووصلت على المشروع وقدروا في المشروع هذا
اللي عايش في الويب ثري قدروا ياخذوا
قرارات لا مركزيه لانه اليوم هم عم
يتعاملوا مع تقنيه الويب ثري دي سنتر وليس
القديمه وقدروا يوزعوا الريسورسز بينهم
بشفافيه وبكل بشكل ديمقراطي طبعا في الليل
الناس برضه بس كان هذا الايفنتافيرس دخلت
حطت النظارات
الفي ارز وحضرت الايفنت وتفعلت فيه زي
اكنها معكم كانت موجوده هون طبعا هذا
الشيء ما بدي احكي اليوم هو اشي بعيد
بالعكس هو اشي كتير قريب وفي كثير عالم عم
تدخل فيه وعم تشتغل فيه
وبلشت يعني هاي التقنيه تنتشر بشكل كبير
وعم بستخدموها ناس كتير
طبعا اذا اليوم بدنا نحكي هيك سريع احنا
زي ما حكينا بلش فيه انه اريد اونلي الناس
بس عم تقرا معلومات من الويب سايت
في الايرلي الفينات تقريبا طلع الويب التو
اللي هو كان نوعا ما فيه وهي ستانلس
يتفاعل معها بشكل بسيط انه انا مثلا اليوم
عندي
فورم جوا الويب سايت عشان الناس تتواصل
معي او في عندي عم بجيبها من الانترنت في
كان ظهور المنصات اللي حكينا عنها قبل شوي
اليوتيوب تويتر فيسبوك عشان الناس تدخل
وتشارك هاي المعلومات وفي الويب 3 اللي
هلا احنا عم نحكي بدايته وان شاء الله راح
نستمر فيه اللي هو عم بحكي عن تكنولوجي
وكيف اليوم انا كل معلوماتي
مشفره لبرا عندي عاليه وما في الاشي
الرئيسي اللي موجود في عالم الويب 3 انه
ما في حدا عم بيتحكم فيه لانه دي سنتر هو
ما في له اونر شيب يعني وحده اللي تتحكم
فيه او تعمل فيه اي مشاكل
طبعا
احنا زي ما حكينا
انه هذا الحكي كلياته راح يكون موزع
وموجود في اكثر من مكان والداتا سكيوريتي
انا البرايفيتي المهمه جدا ما راح تكون
مملوكه من شخص واحد وطبعا توسعها وانها
راح تكون سيملس احنا يمكن اليوم حكينا عن
جزء من من الافكار اللي موجوده
وكل هاي الامور بس توحدها مع بعض وجودها
مع بعض راح يعمل عنا عالم متكامل من من
هلا كل هاي المصطلحات اليوم موجوده في
عالم الويب 3 عم نحكي
ماشيين ليرنينج اي اي كل الامور اللي
سمعتوها اليوم واكثر راح تكون موجوده في
الويب 3 لانه هو عم بيجمعهم في كل يعني
بيجمع كل الايمرجن تكنولوجيز في في الويب
ثري بس النقطه المهمه اللي بهمني انا
اليوم اطلع فيها من هذا السيشن انه كل هذا
الحكي راح يعطينا اشي بنفت كثير عظيمه غير
البرايبيسي والسكيوريتي انه راح يعطينا
تايم ان اكثر نعيش في حياتنا بشكل افضل
لانه في كثير امور عم تعملها روبوتس او عم
تعملها ماشي عم تصير اوتوماتيك بشكل او
باخر
زي ما حكيت اليوم الويب ثري هو اشي
يعني حقيقي وموجود وراح يكون في الفيوتشر
القريب بس خلينا نتفاعل عن جد نحقق كل
اللي تعلمته اليوم انه يصير موجود في في
عالم شكرا جميعا
[تصفيق]
شكرا الك
ضايل عندنا اخر متحدثين وبعديها حيكون
الختم ما قبل اخر متحدث معنا لليوم هو
المهندس بلال الحفناوي مهندس بلال عضو
مميز في مجلس مفوضيه هيئه تنظيم قطاع
الاتصالات منذ عام 2019 يمتلك خبره 20
عاما بقطاعي الاتصالات والتكنولوجيا
المعلومات وعمل مع عده شركات عالميه من
مزودي الشبكات مثل هواوي وموتوريلا ونوكيا
وسامسونج الكترونكس خلينا نرحب مع بعض
بالمهندس بلال
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]